si les faits sont avérés ils sont
évidemment très grave
voici la réponse de l'elysée alors que
vient d'être révélé un potentiel
espionnage du maroc de l'un des
téléphones à des manuels macron selon
nos confrères du monde
une enquête est ouverte à paris pour
faire la lumière sur l'utilisation du
logiciel espion israélien elia zus pour
rappel elle de très nombreux
journalistes opposants et militants des
droits de l'homme ont été ciblés pour le
conte d'une dizaine de gouvernement en
juin tout de suite 4 ap ethnique devant
l'elysée pour plus de précisions bonsoir
cattier à leur nouveau rebondissement
dans cette affaire après les premières
révélations sur l'espionnage des
journalistes le consortium
d'investigation a déterminé que de
nombreux politiques français avaient été
ciblés notamment le président de la
république emmanuel macron et edouard
philippe
alors premier ministre à l'époque
et oui en effet un c'est une bombe qui
explose en deux temps en effet hier des
révélations surgies expliquant que 50000
personnes avaient été la cible
potentielle d'un logiciel espion
pegasus de la société israélienne et
nassau et ce pour le compte d'une
dizaine d'états l'arabie saoudite le
mexique ou encore les émirats arabes
unis et la dernière révélation choc
c'est que les numéros des manuels macro
et d'edouard philippe figurer sur cette
liste ainsi que ceux de 14 ministres en
exercice en 2019 il y avait par exemple
gérard gérald darmanin ou encore bruno
le maire et par qui est bien car partie
était il est écouté potentiellement et
bien tout comme nos confrères
edwy plenel et lénaïc bredou de
médiapart par les services secrets
marocains le maroc aurait fait espionner
ou voulu faire espionner dix mille
personnes dont 1000 en france et sur
cette liste figurent également des
parlementaires de l'opposition comme
adrien quatre mains ce député insoumis
ou encore robert ménard le maire de
béziers et même alexandre benalla ses
dires à l'assemblée nationale cet après
midi c'est évidemment le choc
jean castex et vu poser la question de
cet espionnage au plus haut sommet de
l'état
interrogé dans l'hémicycle il a expliqué
que des investigations qui n'avait pas
abouti à ce stade avait été ordonnée
donc peu de clarté en ce moment de la
part du gouvernement
mais si cet espionnage était avérée cela
signifierait de graves problèmes
diplomatiques potentiel avec le maroc et
cela nous place aussi face à notre
impuissance au niveau des nouvelles
technologies du renseignement et
d'espionnage et pourtant les
journalistes alerte depuis plus de trois
ans sur la dangerosité de ce logiciel
pegasus
je vous propose d'écouter des réactions
indignées de parlementaires cet après
midi à l'assemblée le gouvernement
israélien est très proche de la société
qui a mis en circulation cette suite
logicielle le gouvernement israélien
d'ailleurs et explique qu'il vérifie les
clients
de cette société privée certes privée
mais qui est sur le sol d'israël donc je
suis pas sûr que ce soit un imbroglio
bilatérales uniquement entre la france
et le maroc et je crois d'ailleurs
j'imagine que les services de
renseignement français travaillent avec
les services de renseignement marocains
donc ça ouvre des tas de questions il ya
deux choses quand d'alleuze que un pays
qui est pas un pays ennemi 1 nous
espionnent ça ça pose question
et puis l'autre chose c'est l'intrusion
dans nos téléphones portables par par
une dispositif qui est un dispositif on
ne sait pas par qui les contrôle et
comment à quoi ça sert c'est terrible
c'est naturellement un scandale
extrêmement choquant c'est une agression
qui est insupportable et que l'on doit
combattre ils puissent est aussi le
signe de la faiblesse de nos outils de
sécurité de protection des plus hauts
dirigeants français donc il faudra en
tirer toutes les conséquences dans la
société israélienne nso affirme qu
emmanuel macron n'a jamais été une cible
ou n'a jamais été sélectionné comme une
cible par des clients de nso mais il ya
aussi une réponse des entreprises qui
sont plus promptes à réagir que des
politiques la filiale amazon web
services qui a disposé de serveurs
utilisés par nso groupe leur ont tout
simplement coupé l'accès à ces serveurs
c'était une partie importante de
l'infrastructure technique et de haine
et son groupe tête un pique nique en
direct depuis l'elysée merci beaucoup
pour tout ces précisions